well the White House has urged all
parties to de-escalate after at least 15
people were killed by Israeli airstrikes
on Gaza on Tuesday the Israeli Army said
it targeted and killed three senior
members of Islamic Jihad at least four
children were also killed in the strikes
Muhammad Jam June reports now from West
Jerusalem
[Music]
Tuesday's pre-dawn strikes on Gaza came
as a surprise
lasting approximately two hours
involving no less than 40 Israeli planes
and targeting three commanders of our
kudz brigades the paramilitary wing of
the Palestinian Islamic Jihad group whom
the Army said were responsible for
recent Rockets fired towards Israel
when Warner's in Gaza gathered for
funerals shock had subsided and anger
had swelled
according to the Palestinian Health
Ministry at least 10 civilians including
women and children were also killed in
the strikes
Islamic Jihad after identifying the
three commanders who'd been assassinated
vowed retaliation
as we celebrate the martyrdom of our
great leaders that confronted the
enemies along the years and their wives
and children and our brave Palestinian
people who were killed with them we
confirmed that this sinful crime will
only increase our faith in God and
accept his fate and persistence in the
path that the martyrs took this path
that will end with the defeat of the
enemy
later in the day more air strikes in one
of the attacks Israel's Army said it
targeted Islamic Jihad members who were
planning to launch missiles from the
city of Han yunus in the southern Gaza
Strip with retaliation expected Israel
has closed roads in southern towns
bordering Gaza and readied Iron Dome
rocket Interceptor batteries by evening
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
emerged from meetings with his security
cabinet together with the ministry of
Defense I directed the Army and the
security establishment to prepare for
any scenario of escalation and possibly
on more than one front tonight we say to
our enemies any escalation on your part
will be met with a crushing response
from our part
the big question now what happens next
with concerns growing about a possible
wider escalation it's been made clear
again that in the absence of a political
solution for Gaza the seemingly endless
cycle of flare-ups won't end anytime
soon
West Jerusalem well Muhammad is a human
rights attorney and he says Israel's
airstrikes are illegal under
international law and are consider the
extrajudicial killings
there's really the Israeli legal system
that uh tries to protect uh the Israeli
occupation forces have been trying in
the LA in in recent decades to a claim
that there is actually a legal uh a
loophole in this mountain in this area
and to claim that this is the part of
Israel's uh uh self-defense mechanism
yet even even the Israeli Supreme Court
with those cases were brought before it
uh the Supreme Court Israel did not even
accept that definition that brought
definition there Israeli Supreme Court
said that there are certain conditions
that must be met before such extra
tradition killing so-called targeted
killing in Israeli illegal terms can be
done and and those conditions are first
of all that the killing of innocent
people
is is proportionate or it doesn't exist
at all or proportionally in this case
when at least eight people or or maybe
10 people actually were killed that are
not targets at all they were women and
children were killed in this
assassination even under Israeli legal
judicial definitions what happened was
actually illegal in terms of filing
lawsuits against the state of Israel and
against the Israeli military forces this
option was in existence in the past
whereby Palestinians could bring
lawsuits against the Israeli military
forces in Israeli courts yet in in in
recent years the Israeli Parliament have
passed many pieces of legislations and
many laws to prevent this uh giving
basically immunity to the Israeli
occupation forces in any act that it
takes against Palestinians in Gaza
declaring us that as an enemy territory
and preventing any Palestinian basically
from Gaza from being able to sue the
Israeli forces in Israeli courts